-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy Award winning actor
currently starring
in "Gutenberg! The Musical!,"
which is on Broadway now
at the James Earl Jones Theater.
Please welcome to the show
for the very first time,
Josh Gad, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
-Fred, I so want to go
to a 1000s party now.
I really I have to go
to an airport this week and go.
-I'm so happy you're here.
And I can't believe
you've never been here.
-I'm so happy that I --
No, but that's your fault.
-Yeah.
I can't invite myself
on your show.
I've tried.
-Yeah.
-But it doesn't work that way,
from what I understand.
-Well, I'm very glad we've
rectified the situation.
And I hope this is a situation
where you come back and back.
-I will be here.
-By the way, I'm so grateful
for the fact that you were here
on a night where
you're doing a show on Broadway.
-I'm going to -- I'm going
to leave here
and I'm going to dance
for another audience.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But for now,
I speak to you.
-Does this serve in any way,
shape or form
as a warmup for you?
-This is my warmup.
-Okay.
-Do you guys want to see
what I do for a warmup?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's very --
So I start off
by doing stretches like this.
-Okay.
Okay. Gotcha.
Which, by the way,
I'm pretty limber
for a guy my size.
[ Laughter ]
So I do this.
-Okay.
-And then I do lip trills.
You guys know
what lip trills are?
Brrr.
-Okay.
-Lip trills. None of you
should do that.
And then -- And then
I sing '80s pop ballads.
-You do?
-I do.
-And have you found
historically,
through a life on Broadway,
that that's helpful for you?
-There's so much falsetto
in '80s songs for some reason.
So go high.
I do "Take on Me" by A-ha,
I do some others.
And Andrew Rannells, my costar,
brilliant costar, by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
He's -- He's not here.
-He's not here. Let's not.
-You don't need a cheer for him.
He -- But -- But he does
Sondheim songs.
So this is very complicated.
-[ Laughs ]
-Just infusion of different
sounds backstage
when you come visit
our dressing room.
-And you have
adjacent dressing rooms.
-Yeah. Unfortunately
for Andrew, that is accurate.
We have --
We're separated by a bathroom.
A lot of bad things
happen in that bathroom
before I go on stage,
but we have a bathroom,
and then our two
dressing rooms.
-Are the walls thin enough
that you don't hear
each other or you do?
-No, they're frighteningly thin?
-Yeah.
-They're frighteningly thin,
uncomfortably thin walls.
-Everything about Broadway
dressing rooms is frightening
compared to what
your expectations are.
They are.
-If you love --
If you love,
like, getting sinus infections,
it's a great place
to hang out.
-Yeah.
-There's a lot --
There's a lot of dust
mites in there, which is great.
-Yeah. You know,
when I've been lucky enough
to go backstage to say hi
to friends and shows, like,
it's so cramped.
-It's very cramped.
You feel bad visiting.
It's like, if --
-You're making me feel bad for
having to go there after this,
actually, like,
now I'm starting...
-It's like going to visit
a friend in an elevator.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's before they go up.
-That is 100 --
Except you go nowhere.
It doesn't even go up and down.
-Yeah.
-You just sit and have to listen
to people going to the bathroom.
-Now, it is crazy.
I mean, you and Andrew
are very young men before you --
When you met...
-Before.
-Before...
[ Laughter ]
You know how time works,
right?
I'm not breaking
any news here, but...
-I was going to say,
"That's so sweet."
Oh, he means 10 years ago.
Got it. Yeah.
-You met
when you were very young.
And now, obviously, you have
these very accomplished careers,
and it does seem
certainly from the outside
that you genuinely
like one another.
-We love each other.
It took me a decade
to get back to Broadway.
I, since "Book of Mormon,"
I've been looking for something
to get back with,
and I got sent this script
by Alex Timbers,
a brilliant director.
-Yes.
And who also did
"Here Lies Love."
-Yeah.
-Which is phenomenal.
Everybody should go see
that show.
It's phenomenal.
And I love that they applauded
more for Andrew,
who's not here than you,
who is here and giving them
entertainment right now.
-Andrew is such a...
-Shame on all of you.
[ Laughter ]
But there -- there's
there's just something
about finding the right thing.
And Timbers called us up
and he said,
"I think you guys
should read this.
I directed it
Off-Broadway years ago.
It's perfect
for the two of you."
We read it and we fell
in love with it.
It was exactly comedically
what I was looking for.
-It's so great.
And now you -- your kids,
I'm curious about your kids,
9 and 12, two girls.
I assume they've been to many
Broadway shows at this point.
-That assumption is incorrect.
-Wow.
-They've been they've been
to many shows.
Not -- not -- Well, I guess
on tour they've been.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Their favorite show
is "Matilda the Musical."
-A great show.
-They've seen that like
six times in London.
And I took them
to a bunch of theater,
but they came to see me...
-In this?
-...in this, which was a very
unique experience.
They've seen me in things like
"Frozen" and things like that.
They've never seen me
on stage before.
And so the girls came, and they
came to my opening and my 9,
my 9-year-old kept waving
to me the entire show,
and I was like, "Stop it,
you're" --
[ Laughter ]
"You're embarrassing daddy."
But my my older one, Ava,
was concerned
because I got one of these
infamous sinus infections
last week on opening night.
So my voice started to go in
in the at the beginning
of the show,
and Ava started crying
because she could tell
that my voice started going
and she looked at her mom
and she's like, "Is,
"Dada going to be alright?
Is Dada going to be?"
And backstage that night,
my singing teacher,
Liz Caplan, was in the audience.
So she comes backstage
and she literally does like
a Mr. Miyagi from "Karate Kid"
and starts getting in there,
and I could suddenly sing again.
And my daughter looked like
Daniel Larusso's girlfriend
at the end of "Karate Kid."
She's like, "Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
She was so proud,
so happy.
-I will say, when --
when, you know,
I've had family
come to shows before,
and my absolute nightmare
would be
if I could see two of them,
and one of them was waving
and the other one was crying.
-Yes.
-I mean, that is like...
When people like my wife
is always like, "Don't over --
It's fine. A lot of friends
are going to come."
I'm like, "But what
if I make eye contact?"
That would just be like one --
Like, if my mom was waving.
-It's too much pressure
to have both waving and crying
and an audience
just wanting to laugh.
-You play two people
with the dream
of getting a Broadway show.
So you're basically looking
for a producer that's --
And you're sort
of pitching this idea.
-Yeah.
So the idea of the show
is that these guys have written
a show about Johann Gutenberg,
the inventor
of the printing press.
I like to call this show the
"Hamilton" of our generation.
And they -- Even though,
technically, "Hamilton"
is the "Hamilton"
of its own generation.
So we, you know,
we play 20 characters each,
Andrew and I,
we wear 150 hats to distinguish
between each of these
characters,
which is a nightmare for someone
as uncoordinated as I am.
And -- And the two of us
are on stage
throughout the entire thing.
-Singing, dancing.
-Do you collapse when it's over?
-Oh, my God,
I literally on two show days
I will go backstage and sleep
on what Andrew calls
my FEMA cot.
I have this little cot
that looks really upsetting
and -- and it doesn't
quite fit my body on it,
so I just sort of like
hang over the edge of it.
But I sleep on my FEMA cot,
I get a little nap in,
I have a nice little dinner,
and then I get back to it.
But, you know, those two show
days, they're, it's a lot.
-You you mentioned "Frozen."
I told my kids
you were coming on tonight.
-Aww.
-They were very excited.
But then it always --
This moment of sadness hits
when they realize it's not
the actual animated character.
-Yeah.
-And at that moment
of sadness hits my daughters
every day when I come home.
[ Laughter ]
Where they go,
this isn't what we
signed up for.
-But at least on sunny days,
they don't have to worry.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's the good news.
Hey, what a delight.
We got to do it again soon.
-I love you asked.
-It was so great to have you
back in New York City?
-I love you guys.
Josh Gad.
"Gutenberg! The Musical!,"
now playing
at the James Earl Jones Theatre.
Go see it and stick around.
We'll be right back
with Joe Paris.